now one of the most controversial
stories of the week is about cheerios
see they got this commercial that
features this biracial family and the
responses from the public was so racist
that cheerios had to disable the youtube
comments check out the commercial
that told me that cheerios is good for
your heart says here that cheerios can
help remove some cholesterol and that's
heart healthy
[Music]
how can anyone hate on that
groundbreaking commercial right there
that was great but i'm gonna be honest
with you it wasn't real realistic at all
like this is how it should have went
down
cheerios can help remove some
cholesterol and that's heart healthy
hey
who poured cheerios on me
little girl you're wasting food again
you don't need hungry people it is in
this world you must be out of your mind
i told you pouring cheerios on my heart
ain't gonna kill my heart disease
he's just messing up a perfectly good
shirt
do you know what kind of shirt this is
this is the sean john exclusive but you
wouldn't know nothing about that would
you because you're too busy pouring
cheerios on people
they're going to tell you white mama to
come clean this [ __ ] up
fixing my food
only one working in here
that's the real for you right there